okay so in this presentation we're gonna
go over kingdom fungi and this picture
right here happens to be my favorite
fungus when I when I first learned that
its name was called dead man's fingers
that just grabbed me I just thought it
was the coolest fungus again they're not
literally the fingers of a dead person
but if you use your imagination it kind
of looks like you can picture the zombie
apocalypse where you have a dead corpse
trying to break free from being buried
and here's its fingers reaching above
the ground so that was kind of that did
it that that was my favorite from there
on this is my favorite fungus but moving
on let's learn some basics about kingdom
fungi
okay so let's look at a few basic
features about fungus so there's fungus
among us here we go one of the more
common misconceptions about fungus is
that because fungus kind of grow in the
plant grow in the ground and some of
them even resemble plants there's often
the misconception that fungus fungi are
photosynthetic like plants and that's
just not true
fungi kingdom fungi 100 percent of them
are heterotrophs there's not one
exception to that rule
so all fungus 100 percent of fungus are
heterotrophs they do not perform
photosynthesis they do not have
chloroplasts and chlorophyll so they
obtain their food from others many of
them are decomposers and they obtain
their food from dead organisms and some
of them can be parasites but none of
them are photosynthetic
we look at this poor fish here in the
picture this fish has a fungus infection
look at look at the the fins of the fish
you can see that the fins of the fish
are rotting away that's because there's
a fungus that is a parasite to this
particular fish and the way fungi feed
is the fungus cells the cells of the
fungus will release digestive enzymes
externally that means the fungus will
release enzymes and to whatever it is
they're growing if the fungus is growing
on dead leaves then the fungus will
release enzymes onto the dead leaves in
the picture fungus are living amongst
the cells of the fish so the fungus are
releasing enzymes and of the cells of
the fish it's causing the fish cells to
digest and then once the fungus digests
the fish externally the fungus will then
literally just absorb the nutrients back
into its body
and one thing also to mention is that
fungus fungi have a cell wall made of
chitin which is a polysaccharide now the
reason for this picture here is that at
a time at a time in science history
fungus were thought to have more
similarities to Kingdom plants fungus
and plants were thought to have more in
common well when we chemically analyzed
- we actually find the opposite that
that fungus have more in common to
animals the picture shows an insect
breaking free from its exoskeleton here
well exoskeletons of insects are made
from chitin the same material that makes
up the cell wall of fungus chitin is
also what makes up our toenails and our
fingernails so animals have body parts
made of chitin as do fungi that's one
reason why we're pretty certain that
fungus and animals are more related to
one another
here we have the above-ground
reproductive structure of a fungus and a
lot of this video we're going to talk
about how fungi reproduce and so the
above-ground structure is what we call a
fruiting body we're gonna go into that
in just a few moments the fruiting body
produces a little tiny reproductive
cells called spores and the spores are
often released into the wind or into the
rain to grow into a new fungus so we're
going to talk more about asexual and
sexual reproduction of fungi in just a
few moments
so I hope you recognize this picture it
shows the six kingdoms of life if you
look at the purple bubble in the middle
the Protista kingdom one of the things
we mentioned earlier in the school year
is that there's a category of Protista
that are called fungus-like protist uh
the slime molds and the water molds well
we're pretty confident in our
understanding of evolution of life on
Earth to say that the fungus-like
protist
were the ancestors to today's modern
fungi just like the animal-like Protista
are the ancestors to today's modern
animals and the plant like Protista are
the ancestors to today's modern day
plants so when we look at the basic
structure here we have a reproductive
cell called a Spore and we'll be talking
about spores more throughout these notes
but a spore has been released from one
fungus and it just landed on the ground
well the spore is gonna multiply and
divide and grow and so when the spore
grows little branches little cells start
to branch out in various directions and
we call these individual branchings of
cells we call them - and as the hyphae
grow they will release digestive enzymes
and absorb the nutrients and as as they
take in more energy they grow in and and
become even larger so the hyphae began
to branch and make more branches and
make more branches and over time the
amount of hyphae just multiplies and
multiplies and becomes larger and larger
and larger and what accumulates
underground is what we call the body of
the fungus the body of the fungus
accumulates underground and there's a
vocabulary word for the body of a fungus
it's called the mycelium so on the
picture you can see that the overall
mycelium is made from dozens and dozens
of hyphae I mean in reality this is just
again an artist drawing in reality
thousands and
and probably millions of hyphae make up
the overall body called the mycelium and
this is all underground for the most
part and I say underground for the most
part because when fungi reproduce an
above-ground structure called a fruiting
body appears the fruiting body grows
upward from the ground the fruiting body
grows upward from the mycelium and the
fruiting body is the reproductive
structure inside of the fruiting body
our little spore producing structures
and these for producing structures will
undergo meiosis to create spores spores
if they're created by meiosis you should
know that spores would be haploid
meiosis is the process where haploid
cells are created and so what we're
gonna focus on for the rest of these
notes is how our fungi classified well
one of the defining feature I want you
to know is that fungus are classified
based on their fruiting bodies so let me
show you a couple pictures of some
fruiting bye
so here's a fruiting body if you use
your imagination this kind of reminds us
of Super Mario and the powerup option
and there's you know kind of a more
typical looking fungus that we're used
to seeing
so now that I've distracted you with a
couple pictures of fungi try to label
these from the previous diagram you know
pause the video because I'm gonna go
over the answer in three two one
so area a would be the above-ground
structure called the fruiting body area
B would be the large underground mass
known as the mycelium we haven't really
learned what area C is called the
diagram we saw earlier was just it was
just labeled the spore producing
structure or the Spore producing
structure is what's different between
the various kinds of fungi sack fungi
have different spore producing
structures zygote fungi have different
spore producing structures Club fungi
have different spore producing
structures so we're going to learn more
about the spore producing structures as
we go through this video an area D the
lion is point the lines the two lines
are pointing to individual hyphae so
there's the general structure of a
fungus
so let's go over how fungi reproduce
asexually it all begins when a sex cell
called a spore lands on the ground so in
our animation that black dot represents
a spore and what I want you to know
about spores is that they're haploid if
you remember happily means it's a cell
that has half the total number of
chromosomes sex cells in general
typically are haploid and so the spore
is a reproductive cell a reproductive
cell of a fungus it lands on the ground
the next step that spore is gonna grow a
bunch of hyphae those little branches
called hyphae in the height they are
gonna branch and make more branches and
make more branches and this big massive
collection of hyphae is going to begin
to accumulate again we call this big
collection of of hyphae the mycelium
this is the body of the fungus and what
I want you to know is that all of this
is happily because it grew from the
haploid spore so so far the fungus is a
haploid organism and then what happens
is an aboveground fruiting body is going
to grow and inside of the fruiting body
are those are more of those
reproductives of more of those
reproductive cells called spores so the
fruiting bodies grow above ground again
everything right now is haploid and
inside of those fruiting body bodies
spores are released and notice in the
animation even the spores are haploid so
asexually when we look at the asexual
lifecycle of a fungus it's a haploid
organism now knowing that this is a
cycle the cycle would then repeat
because some of those spores will land
on the ground create their own hyphae
and the process simply continues one
organism reproducing more and more and
more others that's what we mean by
asexual reproduction
well let's look at the sexual form of
reproduction sexually I'm going to show
two different fungal spores and I'm
gonna color code them so there's the
spore of fungus a the yellow sport it
just landed on the ground and I want to
mention that spores are haploid so here
comes a spore a blue spore represented
from fungus B so two individuals here
but again both spores are haploid
nothing out of the ordinary they're both
spores are gonna grow a bunch of hyphae
and the hyphae are gonna make branches
and make more hyphae and the hyphae of
the hyphae are gonna branch to make more
hyphae and a large underground mass of
hyphae accumulates and we call this
large underground mass my seal and watch
the animation in the animation a blue
mass of mycelium just accumulated and
now a yellow mass of mycelium just
accumulate it's a to fungi fungi yellow
and fungi blue now notice where they're
connecting in the middle so what happens
here is the hyphae of the two fungi are
gonna fuse together and so when a
haploid - yellow fuses with the haploid
- blue haploid fuses two haploid haploid
plus haploid I hope you know makes
diploid and so the diploid part of the
fungus now grows from that that green
yellow plus yellow combined to blue
makes green that's why I chose those
colors that's the diploid fungus that's
a new individual that's a new fungus
organism that was created from the two
haploids and as the process continues
that green diploid mycelium that green
diploid fungus is going to produce its
own fruiting body watch the animation
above-ground a fruiting body is created
now all of that is even diploid the
fruiting body is diploid but what it
releases are spores
and when the spores are released I hope
you know that the spores are haploid so
watch the animation so a bunch of spores
are released and look at that green
spore that landed there on the left that
spore is haploid so if I were to ask you
oh okay if I were to ask you the the
green haploid dot the green haploids
four came from that diploid above-ground
fruiting body so if it started diploid
but ended half-light i hope you know
meiosis must have been the key division
there and finishing off this particular
animation here that green haploid spores
ifá and the height they will branch to
make a big mass of mycelium and the
cycle repeats itself
looking at a category of fungus called
the bread molds bread molds often
decompose dead matter and we often we
often discover that when we're really in
the mood for a sandwich you really want
you know that deli meat that you really
like you get out the deli meat you get
out the cheese you get out all the
condiments that the mayonnaise the
mustard that you cut up some Tomatoes
maybe some lettuce maybe some onions and
then you reach into the bag of bread and
the breads all moldy or the crust is all
moldy well then y'all that we faced that
decision how bad do you want that
sandwich do you just cut off the moldy
crusts and pretty continuous and--which
or do you throw the bread away and go to
the store and buy a new loaf of bread
we've all had that dilemma what have you
chosen and it is moving on to the bread
molds the bread molds can reproduce
sexually or asexually in the animation
you can see spores are being really
released again spores are haploid so
haploid spores are being released into
the air maybe the spores will land on
another loaf of bread maybe the land and
with an open window maybe the spores
will drift through the air and outside
and land in the dirt
one thing I want to mention about bread
molds is that they're a great example of
a mutualistic organism bread molds have
a mutualistic relationship often with
plants there's a special kind of bread
mold by the name of mycorrhizae and it's
a great example of a mutualistic
relationship with plants mycorrhizae is
a fungus and the plant live in mutualism
a relationship where they both benefit
what i'm going to show you in a moment
is that the fungus the mycorrhizae
funguses because it obtains sugars from
the plant the plant does photosynthesis
makes its own sugar and the fungus can
obtain and take some of that sugar the
plant will often obtain phosphorus from
the hyphae of the fungus plants need
phosphorus and other nutrients I guess
phosphorus is not the only nutrient but
it's a very important one and so plants
grow better with these fungi and you can
even see it in the picture look at the
picture it's a great example of this the
plants on the unlabeled without in the
picture these are the control group
these plants have been grown without the
mycorrhizae fungi in their roots and the
plants labeled with these are plants
that have been grown with the
mycorrhizal fungi in the roots so the
conclusion is pretty straightforward the
conclusion is that plants and crops tend
to grow better with this mycorrhizae
fungi and this is something that
agriculturalists
and farmers are definitely taking notice
and trying to incorporate into their
growing of crops
so here's a nice little cute little
poster I found for why do you why do
your plants need mycorrhizae fungi and
if you just read through it if the
picture is a little blurry I hope not
mycorrhizal fungi are beneficial and
they form a symbiotic relationship with
plant roots the fungi receives sugar
from the roots in exchange it absorbs
and sends soil nutrients and water back
to the plant so it's a great example of
a mutualistic relationship
when we look at bread molds here's a
here's a bread mold with the fruiting
body above ground the name of the spore
producing structures we never said this
earlier but the name of the spore
producing structure of bread molds is
called the sporangia so make sure you
know that if you're in my biology class
if I were to ask you on a test what do
we call the spore producing structure of
bread molds I hope you would say
sporangia or if I were to ask you which
fungi produced their spores inside of
objects called sporangia I hope you
would say the answer would be bread
molds
when we look at the club fungi here's
three common examples of club fungi
mushrooms puff balls and shelf fun and
the reason they're called Club fungi if
you use your imagination the the
fruiting body often resembles a club
shape some often will describe it it's
kind of like an umbrella shape so if you
look at our most famous cartoon
character that always carried a club
here is bamm-bamm rubble from the
Flintstones he always carried a club
with him well use your imagination does
that do those blue fruiting bodies right
there resemble clubs how about that what
does that green free excuse me does that
red fruiting body resemble a club that
grey one brownish grey one yeah that
kind of looks like a club to me and
let's not forget when they grow their
fruiting bodies above ground the
fruiting body structures the Spore
producing structures will create spores
through the process called meiosis in
the picture you can see the name of the
spore producing structure it's called
the basidiomycetes
often we also see examples of club fungi
that cause disease and plants here's two
pictures of plants that have a fungus
disease the picture on the right shows
corn smut if you there's clearly
something wrong with this call these
corn kernels kernels of corn are not
supposed to be green and big and brown
and puffy like that these this this corn
plant in the picture has a fungus
infection the picture on the left shows
leaves infected with a rust fungus you
can see how it has a rusty color to it
so Club fungi can often be parasitic and
cause infection
so going back to the name of the spore
producing structure the plural version
is the word basilia if I were to ask you
on a test what do we call the spore
producing structure of club fungi I hope
you would say basilia or if I were to
ask you which fungi have spore producing
structures known as basilia I hope you
would say Club fungi and then another
group of fungi I want you to know are
called the sack fungi the picture shows
yeasts morals and truffles as common
examples often we even get antibiotics
from sack fungi the picture of the Left
shows a green mold growing on an orange
the green mold is the name Penicillium
it's a it's a mold it's a fungus and
from this Penicillium fungus we've
learned to harvest the antibiotic known
as penicillin the reason they're called
sac fungi is because they're fooding
bodies resemble a sack here's two very
nice pictures showing sex also they're
fruiting body it resembles a sack but it
also reproduce will produce haploid
spores by the process of meiosis and the
haploid spores are often released into
the air many sac fungi are edible and
considered a delicacy in in parts of the
world the picture shows crispy veal
sweetbreads filled with truffles looks
very appetizing very delicious
so in this picture we have the final
name of the spore producing structure if
I were to ask you on a test what do we
call the spore producing structure of a
sack fungi here is your answer the sport
producing structures of sack fungi are
called a sky a sky is plural if I were
to ask you the other version of the
question if I were to say which fungi
creates spores and structures known as a
sky I hope you would say oh that's the
sack fungi and when we wrap up these
notes here's a friend from a few months
ago called lichen if you remember lichen
from our ecology chapter we mentioned
they're often called a pioneer species
because they can grow in rocks we also
mentioned that they are a great example
of a mutualistic relationship to
organisms living in a close relationship
where they both benefit the two
organisms are fungus and algae and the
reason this is a great example of
mutualism where they both benefit is
because when you look at them and you
figure out what do they gain well the
fungus because it's a decomposer and it
does external digestion the fungus can
partially digest the algae and obtain
nutrients you might think well isn't
this a parasitic relationship because
the algae is being harmed well remember
that algae need a home to live in they
need a moist environment and that's one
of the advantages that the algae obtains
from the fungus Moisture is trapped
inside the hyphae also the algae has
substance to grow upon algae can't
really grow on bare rock but the fungus
can and so in this case they absolutely
do both benefit the algae would could
not even exist without the benefit of
the fungus
okay so now that we've reached the end
go ahead and pause the video and try to
answer these questions on a separate
sheet of paper if you're in my class I'd
be happy to check your answers either
before class or after class one day so
go ahead and pause the video and try to
complete these good luck